[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo Krimi-Fans wir lösen heute ein
Versprechen ein ich bin Stefan Netzeband
und ich bin Mirko Kasimir hallo und
heute geht es hier um eine Mordserie die
wir schon angekündigt hatten wir haben
euch in dieser true crime-reihe ja schon
mal Karl Großmann vorgestellt den
brutalen Serienmörder aus Berlin
Friedrichshain der konnte immer wieder
Frauen überreden bei ihm als sogenannte
haushälteren anzufangen nur um sie dann
zu misshandeln und zu töten bis er
schließlich auf frischer Tat ertappt und
zum Tode verurteilt wurde daran konnte
auch sein Anwalt Dr Erich frei nichts
mehr ändern obwohl er schon Erfahrung
mit Ungeheuern wie groß man hatte wenn
euch das jetzt nicht bekannt vorkommt
hört unbedingt auch die Folge der
schlechter vom Bahngleis hier bei Tatort
Deutschland darin wird klar wie
chaotisch brutal und anonym Berlin in
diesem 1910er und 1920er Jahren war
sowas wie ein Paradies für perverse
Mörder
und so hat es da Anwalt Dr Erich Frey
erst ein Jahr vor Großmanns Hinrichtung
einen anderen Killer verteidigt und bis
zur Vollstreckung seiner Todesstrafe
begleitet Friedrich Schumann den
Schrecken von Falkensee
[Musik]
seinen Fall erzählen wir heute anhand
von zeitgenössischen Artikeln unserer
Schwester Zeitung BZ die gab es nämlich
schon damals
zusammengefasst hat diese Geschichte der
Autor und frühere Chef des
Deutschlandfunks Ernst Elis und Achtung
wir beginnen die Geschichte an ihrem
Ende
[Musik]
aufgetischt werden Buletten mit Teltower
Rübchen zum Nachtisch grießflammerie mit
blaubeerkompott dazu eine Berliner Weiße
mit Schuss eine halbe Stunde dauert das
mal das henkersmal der Mann in Zelle 301
stochert mit einer hölzernen Gabel auf
dem Teller herum aus Holz damit er sich
oder die Aufseher nicht verletzen kann
bevor ihm der Henker mit dem Beil im
hinrichtungsschuppen des Gefängnis ist
Plötzensee den Kopf abschlägt dieser Typ
der da zum letzten mal was zu essen vor
sich hat trägt weiße Stoffstreifen auf
der stiftungskleidung als Kennzeichen
für Mörder es ist der Schlosser
Friedrich Schumann zuletzt wohnhaft in
Spandau starkener Straße 6 im Volksmund
heißt Schumann mittlerweile der
Schrecken von Falkensee er ist Hager hat
kurzes Haar markante Wangenknochen und
sehr ernste etwas verloren rein
blickende Augen
die BZ hat im Sommer 1919 mehrfach über
schaurige unaufgeklärte Morde in den
Wäldern nördlich von Spandau berichtet
zuletzt über den Mordanschlag auf einen
Förster der mutige Beamter hatte obwohl
selbst schwer verletzt dem Angreifer mit
seiner Schrotflinte noch eine schwere
Wunde an der Schulter zufügen können der
Täter flüchtete aber der Förster
diktierte in der Nacht bevor er dann
seinen Verletzung erlag eine Art
Steckbrief seines Mörders ein
mittelgroßer Mann entfällt grauer
Kleidung mit Rucksack
die Fahndung lief an und schon drei Tage
später am Donnerstag den 21 August
präsentierte die BZ ihren Lesern das
Geständnis des Falkenhagener Mörders
denn zwei Tage nach dem Verbrechen hatte
Schumann geplagt von Schmerzen die
Spandauer Praxis des Arztes Georg
templing aufgesucht und auf seinen
blutenden Oberarm gezeigt er sagte ich
habe beruflich mit Zündern zu tun habe
Pech gehabt und bin durch die
sprengstücke verletzt worden bitte
helfen sie mir
aber Dr tepling wird misstrauisch er
schickt den Patienten erstmal unter
einem Vorwand zurück ins Wartezimmer
dann sagt er seiner Frau sie solle
schnell zur Polizei gehen während der
Spandauer Allgemeinmediziner den Mann
dann versorgt kehrt Frau templing mit
zwei Polizisten wieder die Beamten legen
dem Mann Handschellen an und nehmen ihn
mit aufs Revier noch am gleichen Abend
so meldet es die BZ gesteht Friedrich
Schumann der Artikel steht zwischen
Meldungen über den Handgranaten Kampf
der Polizei mit einem Mörder und einem
Bericht über einen französischen Berlin
Besucher der auf der Friedrichstraße
erstochen wurde und neben Artikeln über
die alltäglichen Banden Angriffe
bewaffneter Ex-Soldaten die überall in
der Stadt auf raubtour gehen während
Schumann nach seinem Geständnis wieder
in die Zelle gesperrt wird lernen wir
mal die Zeit in der erlebte etwas besser
kennen und ihn selbst
Berlin nach dem Ersten Weltkrieg Waffen
gibt es auf dem Schwarzmarkt wie Brot
beim Bäcker und die Stadt ist bevölkert
von vielen Kriegsveteranen die an Körper
und Seele völlig verkrüppelt sind
während die Kriminalität zunimmt ist die
Polizei gerade erst dabei moderne
Ermittlungsarbeit zu entwickeln im
Kaiserreich war die Schutzpolizei so was
wie ein Anhängsel des Militärs und wie
es keinerlei Spezialisierung auf noch in
den ersten Jahren nach dem Krieg liefen
Mord Ermittlungen eher aus dem Bauch
heraus gab es einen ungeklärten
Todesfall wurde erst umständlich nach
einem Kommissar gesucht der den Fall
bearbeiten sollte so verging wertvolle
Zeit am Tatort wiederum wurden oft
Spuren übersehen oder sogar von den
Beamten selber verwischt sie räumten
nämlich erstmal auf ehe der Kommissar da
war es vielen Leuten wie Schumann also
leicht unentdeckt zu wüten und Schumann
war schon in jungen Jahren gefährlich
Werbung heute möchten wir euch den
Podcast Darwin gefällt das empfehlen den
history-podcast über die epic fails der
Menschheitsgeschichte die Menschheit was
für ein Erfolgsstory wir wären nicht da
wo wir sind wenn ich über Jahrtausende
hinweg viele kluge Köpfe viele geniale
Ideen gehabt hätten zum Beispiel Charles
Darwin Vater der Evolutionstheorie
survival of the fittest aber was ist
eigentlich mit dem oder der
zweitstärksten bei Darwin gefällt das
geht es um Ideen die sich eben nicht
durchgesetzt haben ihr lernt Menschen
kennen die sich in ihrer Mission
gnadenlos überschätzt haben oder halt
irgendwo falsch abgebogen sind die Hosts
an der Bühler und Christian alt
überraschen sich gegenseitig in jeder
Folge mit einer neuen Geschichte
Darwin gefällt das gibt es auf dem
Podcast Player eures Vertrauens jeden
Montag neu hört jetzt rein
Werbung Ende
Friedrich Schumann wird 1893 im
städtischen Krankenhaus zu Spandau
geboren sein Vater Hermann ist ein
vorbestrafter Kleinkrimineller und
Alkoholiker Friedrichs erstes Opfer ist
seine Cousine harter Ball zu weit die er
am 14 mai 1908 bei einem Waldspaziergang
im Falkenhagener Horst erschießt weil
sie ihm zu laut ist da ist Friedrich
gerade 16 er stellt den Vorfall vor
Gericht tatsächlich erfolgreich als
Unfall da und kommt mit einer geringen
Jugendstrafe davon später schildert er
seinem Anwalt die Tat übrigens dann doch
als Mord
1911 erschießt Schumann eine Frau auf
einer Chaussee bei Falkenhagen und
wieder behauptet er es habe sich um ein
Versehen gehandelt man glaubt ihm erneut
er geht diesmal aber immerhin für neun
Monate ins Gefängnis nach seiner
Entlassung wird Schumann scheinbar
vernünftig er fängt als Schlosser im
Reichsbahnausbesserungswerk an
1914 wird er in die Armee eingezogen und
kommt nach zwei Jahren Kriegsdienst
zurück geehrt mit dem Eisernen Kreuz
über die Kriegsjahre ist wenig bekannt
aber wahrscheinlich steht schon an
seinen mordhunger auch an der Front und
wird dadurch sogar noch blutrünstiger
denn nach seiner Rückkehr aus dem Krieg
legte es richtig los
im September 1916 feiert Schumann 8
Schüsse auf den Forstbeamten Köpke ab
trifft ihn aber nicht im Mai 1917 tötet
er dann einen Nachtwächter in
Falkenhagen im Juli 1917 zwei Polizisten
im Winter darauf begeht Schumann
Brandstiftung ein halbes Jahr später
tötet er den Lehrer Paul in Spandau und
Falkenhagen geht mittlerweile die Angst
um jemand schießt auf Spaziergänger
Jäger Dienstmädchen und eine
Lokomotivführer er überfällt Liebespaare
töte zunächst die Männer vergewaltigt
und tötet anschließend die Frauen wenn
ihr die Folge über Karl Großmann hört
versteht ihr jetzt vielleicht wie
verrückt diese Situation in Berlin in
diesem Jahren war im Osten und der Mitte
der Stadt in Kreuzberg Friedrichshain
und Mitte wütet der Killer vom Bahngleis
in den Kanälen werden immer wieder Teile
von Frauenleichen gefunden und weit im
Westen entspannter und Falkensee Ball
Friedrich Schumann reihenweise Leute ab
das alles zusammen ist sowas wie das
wahre Babylon Berlin am 18 August 1919
trifft der Mörder im Wald auf sein
letztes Opfer den Forstaufseher Wilhelm
nielbock aus Spandau der spricht
Schumann an der im daraufhin zweimal in
die Brust schießt nielbock schafft es
noch seine Schrotflinte auf den
Flüchtenden abzufeuern der Vater von
drei Kindern stirbt später im
Krankenhaus
aber er kann den Täter vorher
beschreiben schlank mittelgroß blond in
feldgrauer Kleidung Schrot in der
Schulter und damit sind wir zurück am
Tag nach Schumanns Verhaftung in der
Arztpraxis von Dr teppichling Tag und
Tag wird der Schwerverbrecher jetzt
verhört und er singt wie eine Amsel
prahlt mit mörderischen Einzelheiten
seiner Taten zuletzt so schildert
Schumann war er bewaffnet mit seiner
Armeepistole einem Totschläger einen
deutlicher einer starken Beißzange und
Gummihandschuhen er habe im
Falkenhagener Forst weitere Opfer
gesucht der BZ muten ihren Lesern
erschütternde Einzelheiten von Schumanns
Taten zu die Leiche eines Mädchens bis
auf Hemd Korsett und Unterhose in
kleidet in einer Höhle vergraben schon
stark verweht daneben die Leiche eines
jungen Mannes
ein Jahr lang füllen
schuhbandsgeständnisse Seite um Seite
seiner Akte dann wird am Landgericht
Berlin 3 der Prozess gegen ihn eröffnet
das Gebäude steht übrigens noch heute am
Ufer der Spree am Tegeler Weg gegenüber
liegt der großzügige Park des Schlosses
Charlottenburg
Schumann wird erstmal ein
Pflichtverteidiger zugeordnet doch der
gibt auf nachdem er die grausigen
Details der Morde erfahren hat die
Justiz in ihrer Not bittet einen der
prominentesten Strafverteidiger Berlins
Doktor Erich frei die Verteidigung des
blutrünstigen Angeklagten zu übernehmen
frei hat sich seinen guten Ruf als
cleverer Strafverteidiger hart
erarbeitet er hat schon reihenweise
milde Urteile in krassen Fällen
herausgeholt unter anderem für Mörder
militante Kommunisten oder zügellosen
nackttänzerinnen für die Zeitungen ist
der Mann ein verlässlicher
geschichtenlieferant und auch diesmal
sorgt freismann dann für Schlagzeilen
die Anklage gegen Friedrich Schumann
lautet auf sieben vollendete und 15
versuchte Morde 23 weitere Verbrechen
sowie 11 no-zuchtverbrechen frei liegt
schon gleich zu Beginn des Prozesses
einen dramatischen Auftritt hin er
steigt auf die Verteidiger Kanzel und
betont wie schlimm er die Taten seines
Mandanten findet ich trete hier vor das
hohe Gericht und muss erklären dass ich
das Mandat mit einem wohl für jeden
begreiflichen Widerwillen antrete in
meinem Gewissens Konflikt ob der schwer
fassbaren Grausamkeit der Taten hat aber
die Einsicht gesiegt dass Quark Gesetz
jede vor dem Schwurgericht Angeklagte
Person einen Verteidiger haben muss so
exzellent frei auch Auftritt im Fall
Schumann ist einfach nichts heraus zu
schlagen zwar fehlen für einige der
Taten die handfesten Beweise dafür
wiegen die nachgewiesenen Morde umso
schwerer und so geht der Prozess am
Spreeufer schon nach acht ver
Anfangstagen zu Ende das Urteil
lebenslange Haft sechsmal die
Todesstrafe sowie weitere Strafen wegen
Brandstiftung und Vergewaltigung aber
erstmal vergehen Monate bis das Urteil
verstrickt wird wie die Zeitung das
tagebuchprotokolliert protestiert
Schumann gegen die Verzögerung Zitat
Schumann verlangt seinen Tod er will
lieber sofort sterben als nicht wissen
was mit ihm geschieht er fordert seinen
schnellen Tod er sitzt seit Juli 1920 im
Plötzensee und wartet dass das ihm
zugesagte Todesurteil vollstreckt werde
er hat nie um Gnade gebeten er hat nur
von Zeit zu Zeit daran erinnert dass er
ein Recht auf seinen Tod habe am 27
august 1921 wird Schumanns Wunsch
erfüllt er wird morgens um 6 Uhr in der
Haftanstalt Plötzen sie enthauptet da
hat sein Verteidiger Erich frei schon
längst wieder anderes zu tun denn obwohl
ihm Mandate wie das von Schumann
angeblich wieder waren übernimmt er im
gleichen Jahr die Verteidigung von Carl
Grossmann der gewitzte Jurist arbeitet
in der Weimarer Republik noch jahrelang
weiter an seinem legendären Ruf aber
weil er Jude ist verlässt er Berlin 1933
und flieht nach Santiago de Chile dort
stirbt er am 30 März
1964 sein Buch ich beantrage Freispruch
war uns bei diesem Fall genauso
behilflich wie beim schlechter vom
Bahngleis Karl Großmann danke dass ihr
zugehört habt und hoffentlich bis zum
nächsten mal euer Stefan und euren Mirko